so let's say we've been given all of
this information about the function G
and its derivatives evaluated at x
equals two so we know G of two is equal
to three G prime of two is equal to one
the second derivative of G evaluated two
is negative one the third derivative of
G evaluated at two is two
so given that what we're being tasked
with is we want to use the second degree
Taylor polynomial centered at x equals
two to approximate G prime of one not G
of one G prime of one and so I encourage
you to pause this video and to try to
think about it on your own so I'm
assuming you've had a go at it so let's
just remind ourselves what the what the
second one a second degree Taylor
polynomial centered at x equals two
would look like for a general function f
of X so f of X f of X would
approximately be equal to it would be F
of 2 F of 2 plus F prime of 2 times X
minus 2 plus F prime prime of 2 times X
minus 2 squared all of that over 2
factorial and that would get us to a
second degree place because when it's X
minus 2 squared this is going to give us
a second degree polynomial now this is
the general case if f is centered at if
we want to find the approximation for F
centered at x equals 2 but we're going
to do it for G prime so let me write
this down all right so I'll do it in
blue all right so we have G prime of X
is what we're going to try to
approximate and then we're going to
evaluate it at x equals 1 so G prime of
X is going to be approximate
approximately equal to well same thing
it's going to be the function that I'm
going to try to approximate evaluated at
2 so G prime of 2 notice so I'm
approximating f of X it's that function
evaluated - if I'm approximating G prime
of
it's that function evaluated at two and
then plus the first derivative of this
thing which is the second derivative of
G G prime prime of 2 times X minus two
and then plus the second derivative of
the function that I'm trying to
approximate but if the second derivative
of G prime is going to be the third
derivative of G so it's going to be G
prime prime prime of two times X minus
two squared all of that over two
factorial
now they tell us what these things are
they tell us they tell us so let me use
some new colors here so they tell us G
of 2 is equal to 3 so this right here oh
actually no that's not we're going to
want to use so they tell us we don't we
aren't using G of 2 they're telling us G
prime of 2 is equal to 1 G prime of 2 so
this right over here is equal to 1 G
prime prime of 2 is equal to negative 1
so this is negative 1 right over here
and then finally the third derivative of
G evaluated at 2 is 2 is 2 and 2 over 2
factorial 2 factorial is 2 times 1 or
it's just 2 so that and that cancel out
so what are we left with for our
approximation our second degree
approximation of G prime of X centered
at x equals 2 we are left with G prime
of X is approximately equal to
approximately equal to 1 1 minus x minus
2 1 minus X minus 2 I guess I could
write that as plus 2 minus X so plus 2
minus X the negative of X minus 2 is 2 2
minus X and then plus X minus 2 squared
and obviously I could simplify this even
more this is 3 minus X plus X minus 2
squared and now I can evaluate it so if
I want to approximate G prime of 1 I
could say G prime
of one is going to be approximately
equal to wherever I see the X is here I
put in a 1 there it's going to so it's
going to be 3 minus 1 plus 1 minus 2
squared well this is going to be 2 and
then 1 minus 2 is a negative 1 but then
if I square it I get a positive 1 so
this whole thing is 1 so 2 plus 1 is
equal to 3 so once again this is an
approximation for G prime of 1 what did
we do here
we found the Taylor series the second
degree Taylor series approximation for G
prime of X set around x equals 2 and
then we use we evaluated that
approximation at x equals 1 to come up
with to approximate G prime of 1 anyway
hopefully you found you found that fun